PROFESSOR: All right.
So Lecture 7 was
about many things--
universal foldings by box
pleating, maze folding,
and then lots of
NP hardness stuff.
So we're going to go through
things in that order.
I thought I'd start by showing
some old history of box
pleating, where it comes from.
The first design is by this guy
Raymond McLain, 1967, design
called the Mooser's train.
And you can see all the creases
are horizontal, vertical,
and diagonal, 45 degrees.
This is the original
handwritten thing,
and this is apparently before
the time of origami books,
for the most part.
So people would
just photocopy this,
and hand it around, just
kind distribute it out
through the origami community.
And kind of spawned a
revolution origami design,
because it was the
first model to make
sort of a very complicated
multi-object piece out
of one piece of paper.
Happened to be a
rectangle of paper,
but a pretty cool design .
And it really got
people thinking about.
And the basic, original
principal in box pleating
was to make boxes, and then find
ways to attach them together.
And it's fairly
powerful and believed
to be universal by
origamists for a long time.
And we proved it with
that cube gadget.
Now, the designs that come
out of the cube gadget
are not especially efficient.
I've got some ways to
optimize it, as you saw,
but at least it proves
everything is possible
that you could
make out of cubes,
you can make out
of box pleating.
Another kind of
influential design
is this black
force cuckoo clock.
For a long time, one of the most
complicated origamis out there.
It was designed by
Robert Lang in the '80s,
and there's a few of
them in existence.
It has lot of detail-- it
has a clock, that's correct
twice a day, and it's he
modeled it after a real cuckoo
clock he saw in
the Black Forest.
It's got a zillion
creases, especially
in this long rectangle of paper.
And there's diagrams for it
in Origami Design Secrets,
if you want to make your own.
And it's also based on
this box pleating idea,
and sort of in the early days
of the tree theory, and so on.
So really, before that kicked
off, box pleating was around.
And people still do
basic box pleating,
although now there's
the fusion of the tree
method with box pleating.
There's a lot of designs
based on that, because they're
easy to fold from
angular perspective,
easy to find where the
creases are, anyway,
that's box pleating.
So next, we go on to-- I
think it's an open problem.
Yeah, this is a
cool open problem.
For some reason, never
thought about it.
I'm sure briefly thought about
it, but never worked on it.
In the same way we get
universal hinge patterns,
box pleating can make any poly
cube, what if you want to make,
out of the simple cube gadget,
can we design an analogous cube
gadget for
tetrahedra, octahedra,
might be nice, regular octahedra
tile space, out of something
like a triangular grid,
maybe with 30 degree lines.
That's a natural
question-- open.
Maybe we'll work on it sometime,
but I think it'd be neat.
You just need a nice
gadget, and then we
know how to compose them by
induction just like in lecture
seven.
So it could be a
fun thing to attack.
Next, we go to maze folding.
So I thought I'd
show-- we've seen
this maze fold-- the 6.849.
So this is folded
by Jenny and Eli
based on the algorithm that
you saw, and you might play
with it on your
problem set three.
Design your own maze.
You can click any
pattern you want.
Make whatever letters you want,
or any other cool orthogonal
pattern.
Marty and I have made a
bunch of different print
designs based around this idea
of taking not just the crease
pattern you get for
folding-- here we're
folding the word yes
in three dimensions--
but we've shaded the original
piece of paper in this pattern.
So that it looks like nothing
on here, but when you fold it,
the shading comes
together to spell no.
So it's kind of ambiguity, or
the shadow of the yes is no,
and so on.
And Jenny and Eli folded
that as well, and here it is.
The first folding.
But our idea is not
necessarily to fold them.
I mean, it's cool that
they can be folded.
That's neat
conceptually, but we also
like to design ones that
really should not be folded.
Next one here is
science and art,
so you fold the science
in three dimensions
and the art is in the
background lurking there.
I imagine this will
never be folded.
It'd be rather painful.
Here's another very
complicated one.
Here we're playing around with
putting little shaded regions
in these squares.
These are just the
squares that end up
mapping to the flat
parts over here.
And so you get--
we took an image
and spliced it up into
thousands of pieces.
So you get-- this is a
photograph of Martin Gardner,
who died a couple
years ago sadly.
We never met him,
but he was the father
of recreational mathematics
among other things.
Also magician--
lots of cool things.
So this is in tribute to him.
And this is our latest
design in this spirit.
We're trying to be a
little more artistic
and just be about the crease
pattern, not necessarily
the folding.
So the 3-D thing that this
folds into is not shown here,
and in theory all these
lines go off to infinity.
But this spells the word glass.
We made it when we were at
the Pilchuck Glass School
this summer.
And it's now on t-shirts of many
glass blowers around the world.
How many of them know
exactly what it folds into,
I don't know.
But that's pretty cool.
So we were working
on glass folding,
so that seemed like a
natural thing to do.
So that is maze folding
and see some designs.
How you can use it
for cool things.
The next topic is
NP-hardness, and that
will be what we spend
most of today on.
And so, first kind
of general question
is what does it all mean?
What does NP-hardness
really tell you?
Can you give me like a
specific instance that's hard,
and-- this is more for people
who haven't seen MP-hardness
before-- the answer is no.
NP-hardness is kind of a
conceptual, philosophical
thing.
No specific problem
is ever NP-hard.
It's all about whole families
of problems being hard.
And really it's about
measuring the growth of problem
complexity with problem size.
So in this case, it's
how much running time
do you need to
solve your problem
as a function of
the problem size.
And we're interested in whether
that grows only polynomially
or it grows exponentially,
and NP-hardness probably
implies exponential growth.
A nice example of this is chess.
So eight-by-eight
chess-- people have
spent many years trying to
solve it and do it perfectly,
and to be the best player.
But from a theoretical,
computer science perspective,
chess in its original
form, is trivial
because it just has a
constant number of states.
You could just enumerate
them all in constant time.
You know who wins in
chess-- probably white.
But it's not very satisfying,
but the more interesting thing
to say is to study
chess as it grows,
and the natural way to make it
grow is with an n-by-n board.
So with an n-by-n
board, if I give you
an arrangement of
chess pieces and I
want to know who wins,
that you can prove
is something even stronger than
NP-hardness called X-hardness.
So there you can actually
prove you need exponential time
to solve n-by-n chess.
And that gives you a sense
the chess really is hard.
There's not going to be a good
algorithm that magically will
solve it for eight-by-eight,
because in general as board
size increases, you know it
has to grow exponentially,
and probably eight-by-eight
is big enough.
That there's no good
algorithm to do it.
You can't prove that
there's no good algorithm
to do eight-by-eight,
but you can
prove there's no good
algorithms to do n-by-n.
So that's the limitation of
theoretical computer science
and of NP-hardness.
So you take any
particular crease pattern.
You want to know
whether it folds flat.
You might be able to do
that by exhaustive search
and exponential
time might be OK,
but you know that as the
crease patterns get big,
you're totally screwed.
So, next question about
hardness is can we
do it with a little
less hand waving?
So in a little bit
more detail, because I
covered a lot of proofs.
So I'm going to
look at two of them.
The simple full hardness--
which is from partition--
and the crease pattern
flat foldability which
is from not all equal
SAT-- 3SAT-- and I'll
give some more details.
So let's start by going
through this proof.
Remember, in general with
an NP-hardness reduction,
we want to take some
known hard problem
and convert it into our
problem, because that proves
that our problem is at least
as hard as the original one.
So in this case, the known
hard problem is I give you n
integers-- a1, a2, up to an.
And I want to know, can I
split them into two groups
so that the two
groups have equal sum?
And here we're mapping that into
the simple fold problem, which
was given a crease
pattern can you fold it.
Can you follow all the
creases flat by simple folds?
We're mapping it
into these lengths--
these lengths are the AIs
between the different legs
of the staircase.
And then there's
this extra stuff.
This is a super long
length-- length l--
and this is a doubly
super long length-- 2l.
And then there's this
frame, which has height 2l,
and this part is aligned
right at the midway.
And so the idea was if there's
a partition-- if there's
a partition of the AIs
into two groups-- call them
Group A and Group
B-- then I'm going
to fold some of the creases.
The ones between any two
guys of different groups.
Because folding here corresponds
to switching directions.
So whenever I fold, I'm kind of
switching which group I'm in,
and then Group A will
be all the up directions
and Group B will be all
the down directions.
So maybe both of these
guys are in Group B
so they both go down, and this
is a Group A guy, so we go up,
and then down, and then up.
And if we get them-- A and
B to be balanced-- then
we'll end up right
where we started.
So we'll end up right at
the middle point here.
And, in that case, there's
these two more folds--
this vertical fold and
that vertical fold.
And then if you-- sorry.
Yeah, I don't have
it drawn here.
When you do one more fold here,
this will fall into the frame,
and if you got this to stay--
if you got this point basically
to be aligned with
here, then going up L,
and then back down to L will
not collide with this box.
It just barely fits,
and so you fold that in.
Then you fold this vertical
line and you fold it back out.
So the goal was just to
get these two folds made.
Once they're made and
it's back out here,
you can finish all folds
that you didn't fold before.
And what we're checking here
is that during all this motion,
you don't get collision
because simple folds are not
allowed to collide
during the motion.
So if this, for example, went
too far down or too far up
and it collided with
the frame, then you
wouldn't be able to make the
second vertical fold here
because you'd have to
bring the frame with you,
and the frame's not
supposed to move.
So in particular,
there's this question.
Seems like we're not
making all the folds,
and that's because I
didn't say the last part.
After you fold it in
here and avoid collision,
you fold it back out with the
second of these two folds.
Then you can finish
all the folds.
Indeed the goal is
to fold everything,
but in order to avoid
collision, when I fold this,
this thing has to be nice and
compact and fit within this 2L
boundary.
Then it goes through.
So what we really
need to show though
at the top level is
given any set of AIs,
we can convert it into an
equivalent simple fold problem.
There's actually two things we
need to check for equivalence.
We need to check that
if there's a partition,
then there's a way to fold it.
We also need to check
the reverse, which
is if there's a way to fold
it, then there's a partition.
But both of these kind of
follow from this argument.
In order to-- when
we make this fold,
this guy's got to-- or
whichever of these two is first.
They're kind of equivalent.
If we collide, we won't be
able to finish the folding.
That's the claim.
You might have done all
the folds over here,
but they'll be the
second of these two,
and so when you do the first,
you'll either get stuck
or you'll be able to proceed.
If you were able to
proceed, you can read off
from the ups and downs here
what the partition was.
So you can convert in either
direction using this reduction.
Any more questions about
the simple folds one?
So, of course, one of the easier
proofs, the crease pattern
flatfold ability is definitely
on the more complicated side,
and this was the
overview of the proof.
Basically there were lots
of little local gadgets.
There's the wire,
which communicates
truthiness or falsity
as we like to say.
Or things like-- the
main gadget is the one
at the top and not
all equal clause,
which forces among the
three wires coming in.
They can't all have
the same value.
So there could be
two true, one false.
Or two false, one true.
But not all true
and not all false.
And then we needed
some auxiliary gadgets
for turning, duplicating,
and crossing over.
Those were fairly
straightforward.
The heart is a wire, and
a not all equal clause.
And so the idea was we were
given a formula-- in this case,
it's a bunch of triples,
and each of the triples
should be not all equal.
And there's like n
variables-- there's
a lot of different clauses
on those variables.
A lot of not all equal
constraints on those clauses.
We want to represent that
by the flatfold ability
of the crease pattern.
So we basically make
all the variables
off the left edge
of the paper here.
We make lots of copies
of them by zigzagging,
and then we make lots of clauses
at the top-- only drawn two
up there-- and then in our input
we're given a bunch of triples
of variables that should
belong to a common clause,
and we just route these
signals to go to that clause.
And then the clauses constrain
the values of those variables
to be not all equal in
the appropriate triples.
And the splitters
down here enforce
all the different copies of
that variable to be the same.
And so any flat
folding will require
these guys are consistently
assigned one truth
value throughout
the construction,
and those clauses will
force not all equal things
to be seen in pairs.
So if there's a flat
folding of this,
you can read off on the
mountain valley assignment
here which one based
on whether it's
left valley, right mountain,
or left mountain, right valley.
You can read of what
the truth assignment is
that satisfies all the clauses.
That was one direction
from flat foldability
to satisfiability of the
not all equal triples
in the reverse direction.
If there's a not all equal
assignment of triples,
you need to verify that this
thing actually does fold flat.
I didn't detail
that, but basically
to do that, you have to prove
that each of the gadgets
works exactly as desired.
So you could really fold it
flat if these have equal value,
for example, and this
has a negated value.
You could actually always
fold the not all equal cause
when it's satisfied.
And then once you know that
each of these gadgets--
because the gadgets are
very small-- once you know
that each of them
folds correctly,
and they have a sort
of comparable interface
because these things are
just extending through,
you could basically paste
glue together all of those
folded states.
So as long as you
verify the gadgets work,
the whole thing
will work provided
there is a satisfying
assignment.
So that's-- yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Can you actually
go in the other direction
properly in the same cell?
Can you map any flat
foldability [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK, can you
map any flat foldability
of a crease pattern
problem to SAT?
That doesn't follow
from this proof,
but I think it should be true.
Uh, let's see-- I think so.
So if I give you
a crease pattern,
I want to know
whether it folds flat.
As mentioned in lecture,
you can determine
where all the facets lie in 2D.
And challenges the
stacking order,
which implies the mountain
valley assignment.
So I think you could
make a variable in a SAT
problem for this piece--
this little polygon lives
in the stacking level.
You have to figure out how many
levels you need, but at most 10
of them, I guess.
And then write down
the constraints
between different polygons
if there are no crossings.
There's a paper
by Jacques Justin
that does that explicitly.
So that should give you a way to
reduce to SAT, which gives you
an algorithm-- an exponential
time algorithm to solve it.
In general, I'm pretty
sure this problem
is in NP, which implies there's
at least an algorithm for it.
But I think in particular,
you can reduce it to SAT.
So that's a good question.
So pretty much
every problem we'll
talk about at least with
origami has a finite algorithm
to solve it, but it's a very
slow algorithm in general.
Of course, there's a lot of
good SAT solvers out there,
and I don't know if people
have actually tried to do that.
I know there are some-- there's
a software called ORIPA, which
in Japan some
versions try to find
a valid folding-- a
valid folded state
by some kind of careful,
exhaustive search.
I don't think they use
SAT solvers though.
You might get more mileage
out of SAT solvers.
Other questions
about this proof?
There's one explicit question
about the reflector gadget.
This probably worth talking
about because these arrows
are maybe not so
obvious what they mean.
So the question is what
is true and what is false.
It's kind of philosophy,
but in this case
these arrows are explicitly
drawn on this diagram.
If you look closely, there's an
arrow this way, then this way,
then this way.
And that's defining what we mean
by the orientation of a wire,
and then if it's a valley
on the left relative
to the arrow, that's true.
If it's mountain on the
left relative to the arrow,
that's false.
And that's why this
is drawn this way
assuming I got it right.
Here it's valley on the
left relative to the arrow.
Here it's mountain on the
So notice these are pointing
in different directions.
So that can get a
little confusing,
but it's kind of what
we want in that proof
because we really want to route
that thing in this direction.
We don't care about
what things look
like relative to
the center here.
Because the center-- the
gadget we are looking at
keeps changing.
So we want to route
this as a single wire.
And this one I
already talked about.
You need to prove
both directions--
that flat foldability implies
not all equal satisfiability,
and the reverse.
OK, we move on.
So now we get to
some new material.
So I mentioned in the
lecture that there
are two hardness proofs.
The one we've been talking
about is given a crease pattern,
does it fold flat?
That's strongly NP-hard.
And the other is if I
give you something--
I might even tell you
it's flat foldable.
That's kind of not too relevant.
But I give you
mountains and valleys,
and I want to know--
I want to find
a valid folded
state of that, or I
want to decide whether
the mountain valley
pattern is valid.
These are strongly NP-hard hard,
and this is a different proof.
It uses completely
different gadgets.
So I thought I'd show you
some of those gadgets.
Sort of the key ones.
So the first part
is the wire, and I
think I made one of these.
Maybe I didn't.
No wire.
Well, this is the end
of a wire-- er, no,
that's not the end of a wire.
Here's an end of a wire.
So the idea here is we've
got a fixed mountain valley
pattern now because that's
no longer free for the folder
to choose.
And you've got
two tabs, and they
could stack one
way or the other.
In this case, they
can stacked like this,
or they can stack like that.
So I've got a
choice in stacking.
That changes the folded state.
That's the choice that the
folder is going to make,
but in either case the mountain
valley assignment is the same.
So that's how we're going to
communicate true and false,
and I haven't
provided orientation.
Should have drawn
an arrow there.
Next gadget is this tab
gadget, and this is just
a tool for building
weird shapes,
and it's kind of similar
to some of the things
you've seen in the
checkerboard folding.
So our crease pattern looks
like this, and fold it flat.
And there's two ways to fold it.
Actually, a few
different folded states.
But in particular,
there's a state
like this where there's this
individually manipulatable tab,
but there's no crease here.
So it can't go backwards.
The crease is in here.
So it's got a fall
down like that.
OK, so what this reduction
does is, ahead of time
basically, force a
lot of these foldings.
And so we start
with a square paper.
We end up with a smaller square
paper with tabs sticking out
in various directions
of various places.
So this is much messier
and it'd be harder
to draw the whole diagram of
what your crease pattern looks
like, but in theory
you can do this.
That's also kind of
like the box pleading
method where you just
make a cube ahead of time,
and it's like you had
a square originally.
There just happens to
be a cube sitting here,
and then you do other folding.
And the angles in this
crease pattern-- these
are not 45 degrees.
They're at a bit
of a weird angle
to basically force
this to happen first.
It can't interact with
any of the other gadgets
that I show you.
Because you've got to get rid of
those angles in the beginning.
Then, the main gadget here
is the not all equal clause,
and that's what I
have folded here.
So it's a little crazy,
but basically you've
got three pleats-- three of
these double pleats coming
together.
These guys could stack-- this
one on top, this one on top.
Now we're the same
for all three of them,
and then you've got this little
twist like thing in the center,
and it's really
hard to draw what
the folded state looks like.
This is what it looks
like within shadow pattern
with transparency.
Here's the real thing.
And also, there's
these yellow tabs
attached at very
specific locations.
And this is a little
hard to imagine.
I encourage you to fold
one of these in order
to really see what's going on.
But as I said before, you've
got-- each of these guys
can be independently stacked
one way or the other.
There's that one or this one
can stack this way or that way
for all three, but we want
to forbid the case where
they're all stacked
the same way.
And the arrows here are all
pointing towards the gadget.
So we want to forbid
the case when they're
all-- when it's
rotationally symmetric.
Gadget is rotationally
symmetric,
but if you choose the layer
order rotationally symmetric,
you're in trouble.
So let me make it
rotationally symmetric.
That would be like this.
So when it's
rotationally symmetric,
you see-- basically
all the panels
you see-- there's three panels.
This one, this
one, and this one.
Each of them has a
tab sticking out,
and basically these tabs have
to also be cyclically ordered,
but it's not possible--
this is hard to do.
It's like this.
You see they're kind
of colliding here.
Because if you look at each
of the tabs in projection,
it collides with where
the tab is attached.
So you basically-- if you went--
so someone has to be the lowest
tab, and that tab will intersect
the other two tabs actually
where that tab is attached.
So it'll penetrate
and you can see
they're not very
happy to stack here.
But if I change the
layer order in any way,
our lowest tab is actually
happy to go behind other layers,
and then you can just stack
them, and they barely fit.
So it's a little tricky to get
all the details here to work,
but I think this particular
geometry-- and the reason
I drew this in this exact way
is to make sure yeah, everything
works.
You do not penetrate here,
which would be a problem.
You do not penetrate
this crease,
which would be a problem.
So the tab just fits in
between here and here,
but it does cross.
If you look at this tab,
it's attached along this edge
as drawn up there.
And this tab here will penetrate
this part of that edge,
and it will penetrate this
part of this edge which
is where this tab is attached.
So they cause trouble in
this cyclic situation,
but when it's a cyclic
like in this picture,
you can put that
bottom tab way down
here and avoid any collision.
Then you can basically
break the cyclic condition,
and you get to stack them
in some linear order.
So it's a little hard to
see without physically
manipulating it.
Feel free to come and
play with that after.
That's their proof.
Now there's also splitters, and
turn gadgets, and crossovers,
but I'll leave it at that.
Those are more similar.
This is the heart of what's
going on in this proof.
So it's a completely
separate proof from the one
that we saw before.
Any questions about that?
All right--
AUDIENCE: Here.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
why the tabs fold.
PROFESSOR: How do the tabs fold?
AUDIENCE: No, why do we need
tabs if everything folds?
PROFESSOR: So the tabs
are being used as a device
to build gadgets.
So the tabs serve no
purpose by themselves.
But this gadget involves
first folding three tabs here,
which are actually
pointing-- they're
pointing in that
direction, I believe.
Then you add this crease
pattern afterwards.
So originally there
are tabs here,
which means there's a
bunch of creases here.
After you fold them, then you
lay on this crease pattern.
So if you unfolded it, you
get some much more complicated
crease pattern.
Which is when I made that,
I just taped the tabs on.
But in reality, first you fold
the tabs so they exist there,
then you fold this on top.
So the fold crease pattern
would be quite complicated.
It's going to have
tabs here, tabs here,
tabs there, and then this
reflected a few times.
And so then when you
fold it-- the fold gadget
is this thing with the tabs.
The tabs are just
like a stepping stone
toward making this gadget.
The other gadgets use more tabs.
Obvious open problem here is
to make a simpler reduction.
Shouldn't have to
be this complicated,
and I've heard Tom Hall talk
about different approaches
for making simpler
NP-hardness proofs,
but we're not there yet.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So these proofs
don't imply anything
about the [INAUDIBLE]?
They can all be very
easily [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this proof
implies these kinds
of tessellation style crease
patterns are hard to fold,
which implies that
in general crease
patterns are hard to fold.
But you could look at some
other specific pattern.
For example, it's
the next topic.
You could look at
map folding where
you have horizontal
and vertical creases
in a rectangular sheet of paper.
Maybe each of these squares
is-- or each of these cells
is a unit square, let's say.
And I give you a mountain
valley assignment on that.
Some of these are mountains.
Some of them are valleys.
Whatever.
And I want to know
does this fold flat?
That we don't know
the complexity of.
Could be solvable by
polynomial time algorithm.
Could be NP-hard.
And this is actually mentioned
in lecture two notes,
but not actually orally.
And so I wanted to
get back to this.
This is from lecture two notes.
2D map folding, Jack
Edmonds poses this problem,
can you characterize flat
foldable mountain valley
pattern.
Is there an algorithm
or is it NP-hard?
And even the 2-by-n
problem was open
when I wrote these
notes in 2010,
but it has since been solved.
So I thought I'd tell you a
little bit about that solution.
So yeah, there can be special
cases of crease patterns
that are easy to solve.
We just know in
general they are hard.
So 2-by-n is this
kind of picture.
So this is what I call
2, counting cells.
This is based on a class
project in this class
from two years ago by
Eric Lew and Tom Morgan,
but the paper got
finished this year.
So it's based on a
series of reductions.
On the one hand, we're going to
start with something called--
OK, so we have map
holding on the left.
We're going to
convert map folding
into a different presentation,
which is NEWS labeling.
We're going to convert that
into something called a top edge
view.
We're going to convert
that into a ray diagram.
And the last part, which I
won't talk too much about,
is we convert that into
something called a hidden tree
problem.
Each of these steps is
fairly straightforward,
but there are obviously
a lot of them.
But in the end, you get a
polynomial time algorithm
to solve this, which implies
you get a polynomial time
algorithm to solve this.
And I'll talk mostly
about these reductions.
It's the same idea
in NP-hardness.
We use reductions from a
hard problem to our problem.
In this case, we're
doing the reverse.
We're reducing our problem
to an easier problem,
so that by the end we
get something that's
so easy we know how to solve it.
The reductions are useful
both for positive results
and negative results.
So let me show you
visually some--
oh, before we get
to the proof, I
wanted to mention this
puzzle which you probably
folded in problem set one.
It's a map folding problem.
It's a 3-by-3 map,
and so we didn't
have any good algorithms
to solve them.
So we used a not
so good algorithm--
namely exhaustive enumeration.
We enumerated all possible
folded states of a 3-by-3 map.
We drew them out graphically.
There's a scroll bar here,
so you don't see them all.
But we put them in
a giant-- I forget,
there's 1,000
folded states or so,
so it's like 100-by--
whatever-- 10 array.
And for each of
them-- so here's where
you're designing your pattern.
So you could make holes.
You could put in patterns.
This is sort of an early design
where it would spell MIT.
The hole would show
the I on another side,
so it's equivalent to
the puzzle you solve.
And this is what
the top looks like.
This is what the
bottom looks like.
So you can hover over these
and change the letters that
appeared, and then
it would show you
what every single
state would look like,
and it would color it in yellow
if one side looked like MIT,
and it would color it in red
if both sides look like MIT.
And the point was
to verify there
was exactly one solution
for that puzzle.
And so we kept-- we
would fold things
to make it a tricky fold.
Then we put into the
software and label things
accordingly, then
put into the software
and see is there unique folding?
And then we could add in
extra misleading clues here,
and see did they accidentally
make an extra solution?
So we could add in
extra stuff to pack in.
As much irrelevant stuff as we
could, and still make it unique
so it's more challenging.
That's a nice use of exponential
algorithms to design puzzles.
All right, but
back to this proof.
So I have here a much
simpler map than this one.
This is what we
call the NEW map.
N-E-W.
So the labeling
here is very simple.
If you look at this crease
pattern, by [INAUDIBLE],
there's got to be three of one
type and one of the other type.
So just label each vertex
by which way is unique.
So from here, the
North direction
is the uniquely label-- it's the
mountain among three valleys.
And then this vertex--
the East label--
is the mountain
among three valleys,
and then the next one is the
West label among three valleys.
Of course it doesn't
have to be like that.
It could, for
example, you can have
three mountains at a vertex,
but then the label of this guy's
going to be W. It's going
to be the one that's
unique among the other three.
So if you fold this
map, it looks like this.
I have one here, but it's
a little hard to see.
We've got lots of back
and forth on the top edge.
Some orienting it so that
the-- we've got 2 by n maps.
So there's two
critical features.
There's the center line.
I'll call that the
spine of the map.
There's the top side
and the bottom side.
When you fold
that-- this is just
a sequence of simple folds.
You see at this last fold, the
top side and the bottom side
come together, and the
spine is-- stays together.
So when I orient it like
this as in the picture,
the top side is where originally
the top and the bottom
of the map all come to here
because of that spine fold,
and the spine folds
are all down here.
You can't see them
here, but there's
you can see them at
the bottom there.
There's some kind of
connections on the bottom,
but there's this nice relatively
one-dimensional picture
up here.
So we're going to draw that.
This is the top edge view.
Got clipped a little
bit, but there's
one more segment at the top.
So that is just this.
See it?
Now there's also
these blue lines.
The blue lines correspond to
what's going on at the bottom
from the spine.
Because if you think
about it, you've
got the-- in a
2-by-n map-- you've
got the top panels and these
edges making the top edge.
And you've also got the
bottom panels and these edges
making the bottom edge.
They come in pairs.
These guys are paired up.
These guys are paired up,
and so on down the line
because they are
joined by a spine edge.
Those spine edges
correspond to the things
on the bottom of the
folding, and they
need to not cross each other.
And that's what's illustrated
by the blue connections.
So the very top edge is paired
with the very bottom edge.
These two-- this panel
here and the back panel
here-- are connected
on the bottom.
And that-- I'm sorry,
that's not true.
This one is paired
with this one.
The top one is paired
with the second one.
So it's actually these two
are connected on the bottom.
That's this little connection
here, and then these guys--
this wraps around everything.
That's that connection.
But what you can't see
it in this folding--
because it's hidden inside--
is that within this connection
on the bottom, there's this
connection on the bottom.
And within that one,
there's this connection.
Now this is OK.
Might look like they're crossing
because they're overlapping.
But as long as they
are nested-- as long
as you don't start from
inside here and go to outside.
That would be a crossing.
You start inside,
you should end inside
like in all these pictures.
If you start outside,
you should end outside.
So that's why-- these guys
are disjoint, so that's OK.
This is nested in
that, so it's OK.
Kind of like
balance parentheses.
And so that's what it makes.
A top valid top edge view.
What's nice about this is it's
a one-dimensional diagram.
What's not nice is it has all
these crossings because there's
the blue stuff on top
of the black stuff.
So it's a little
hard to find-- we're
trying to find a
valid folding state.
We're trying to
find one of these.
We're not restricting ourselves
to simple folds here yet.
Simple map folding we already
solved in lecture two.
So this is all-- I should've
said non-simple folds.
That's what makes
it hard, and that's
what's still open
for 3-by-n maps
if you don't know how to do it.
But for 2-by-n maps,
we've made two steps here.
We have another view,
which is the ray diagram,
and this is really
specific to 2-by-n.
And it lets us reduce
to a tree problem.
So before we get there,
let's talk in general
about the top edge view.
You can actually convert from
the North, East, West, South
labeling to a top edge
view in the following way.
Whenever-- and you can kind
of see what's going on.
So first we have an n.
So we've got these
two guys, which
are just paired
together happily.
That's the beginning of the map.
Then we turn left, and we've got
this guy paired with this guy.
And so, in general,
whenever you have a North,
you turn left with
your two guys.
So that's what happens.
Then we hit an East in
the map, and what happens
here is this guy turns right,
but this one turns left.
This is what you might
call an inside turn.
It's like an inside
reverse fold in origami.
And in general, whenever
you have an East,
you turn inside like that.
So this guy's paired
with that one,
and now this guy's
paired with that one.
They both turn in.
And then it's symmetric.
Next one is a w, which is
the opposite of an e, which
means you turn out here.
And in general, whenever you
have a West, you turn out.
And a South, you turn right.
So those are the
four possible things
you could imagine when you
have a pair of things turning,
and those exactly correspond
to N, E, W, and S.
So it's clear what you need
to do in this situation,
but there's flexibility, right?
For example, this guy--
when you turn out-- here
I turned out to the
very next layer,
but this could have
turned out to go up here.
Would that be OK?
Ah, no.
If this one turned
out to go up here,
that edge up there would be
paired with this one down here.
So there'd be a blue
line going like that,
and that would be a
crossing situation
because that blue line
would cross this one.
Because it starts inside
and it goes to outside.
So it's a little tricky.
This definitely gives you
some of the layer constraints,
but it doesn't
check for crossings.
Which is the big
challenge in this problem.
So we're going to
simplify this diagram.
So just think about
top edge views.
Forget about map folding now.
You can forget about
the previous layers,
and we are now focusing
on this reduction.
So we've got top edge view
converting to ray diagrams.
You can see it's much simpler.
This is the ray diagram
of that picture.
And essentially--
there's two ways
to think about what we're doing.
Instead of having two edges,
and we track two edges turning,
we just want one edge.
That's one thing we're doing.
You can think of that as
tracking the spine instead
of the top and the bottom sides.
But it's a little-- ray diagrams
are going to get confusing.
I'll just tell you
that right now.
Every time I look
at it, I understand
it a little bit
more, but it's not
going to be obviously that
this is equivalent to this.
I'll just tell you--
here's an alternate way
to think about it.
Basically, the vertical--
the y direction
here is going to
be nesting depth.
So whenever we go in
like this, we go deeper.
So for whatever reason,
I flipped the labeling,
but it is indeed East.
When you go in, you go down.
I should have just moved these
two figures so they correspond,
but when you go East you go
down a layer because you're
nesting deeper.
And when you go West,
you're going out,
so you go up a layer in this
new weird ray diagram view.
And North and South turn out
to not turnaround in this view.
We're just going to
fire a ray downward,
and there's either a
North ray-- a blue one--
or a South ray-- a red one.
And so if you follow
this diagram, it's N-E-W.
So first we have an N, which
means we shoot a ray down.
Then we have an E, which
means we turn downwards.
And then we have a W, which
means we turn to go up a layer.
And I haven't told you what
the constraints are here,
but I claim this is a valid
folding just like that one.
And it's obviously a
lot easier to draw.
It's a much slower complexity.
But the cool thing
is you no longer
have these crossing parts.
So let me show you--
first, let me tell you
what the constraints are.
So in general, you're going
to have lots of downward rays.
This is a North.
This is a South.
A North, a South.
So if you had like N, S,
N, S, in your pattern,
it's just going to
be a straight segment
with downward rays
of different colors.
First constraint is whenever you
have a an N ray-- a North ray--
it has to hit another North
ray or just go off to infinity.
And the same-- South rays
can only hit South rays
or go off to infinity.
So they line up in
this way, but you
can stretch the x-coordinate
to do whatever you want.
This corresponds to basically
jumping over a bunch of layers.
When you turn in
your folded state,
you can skip a bunch of
layers and just go up here.
So that corresponds to jumping
over a bunch of folds here.
But in particular
we get these things
called constrained segments.
Constrained segments
are portions
of this black spine between
two rays that below it only
see black.
OK, so for example, this
one is unconstrained,
because below it, you
can see off to infinity.
So that's unconstrained.
We don't care about that one.
But among unconstrained
segments--
these are two
constrained segments--
we want that all of the rays
that they see below them--
so here I see one red
ray, one blue ray-- I want
the number of reds
and blues to be equal.
So this is valid because
there's one red, one blue.
This one is invalid because
there's two blue and one red.
This turns out to be
the right constraint.
Essentially this is saying
however much you spiral,
you should spiral.
That's the intuition.
So here you're spiraling
twice, unspiraling once.
So you're trapped inside, and
so these folds cannot actually
come together.
The rays coming
together correspond
to a nice nesting
between two North folds.
So it's not obvious,
but this turns out
to be the only
constraints you have.
The black should
not cross itself.
Constraint segments should
be valid in this way,
and blue should hit blue
and red should hit red.
So that's not obvious,
but it's true,
and then you can take very
complicated diagrams like this
and simplify them into
these nice pictures.
So these are two
different foldings
of the same pattern,
which I guess
is N-E-N-- I can see
that easily here.
You could have also
extracted it from here.
There's two foldings
because these two layers
could go here in the middle.
Or they could be pushed
up to fit in here,
and then we get this picture.
And in the ray diagram--
you can see this
pretty easily-- either you have
these n rays just both go off
to infinity, and this is an
unconstrained segment so we
don't care about that there's
only one North ray below.
Or, you can extend
the x, because I
can stretch the
x parts however I
want and make these blue
segments align with each other.
And that corresponds
to this folding.
So really, all folded
states of the original thing
are represented by
the ray diagram.
Of course, if I had any
W, this would be valid,
but this would not be that.
N-E-S-- blast from the past.
If I had N-E-S, then this would
be blue, this would be red,
and so this would be valid.
But this would be
invalid, and so on.
So it's obviously a lot
easier conceptually,
but you can also-- and here's
a more complicated algorithm.
You take a really crazy map.
This notation, by the
way, was introduced
by Jacques Justin
like late 1980s.
You may remember his name
from Kawasaki-Justin theorem.
So at the same time he
was looking at map folding
and he came up
with this notation,
the ray diagram was introduced
in the open problem session
in this class two years ago--
or actually five years ago
if I recall correctly-- by
David Charlton and Yoyo Zhou.
And then it was picked
up again two years ago,
and finally we took
this ray diagram
and came up with an algorithm.
So how does the algorithm work?
Here's a ray
diagram-- the black,
and the red, and the blue.
We observe that the blank
space here between the spine
stuff-- between all the black--
is kind of a tree structure.
You've got-- and
that's what's drawn
in cyan with the red dots.
So if you draw a node every time
you turn around on the outside.
Then you say, well, I can get
from this node to this one,
so I'm going to draw
a segment there.
And I can get from
this node to this one
without crossing any black,
so I'll draw a segment there.
That's sort of it on that side.
There's nothing else down here.
That sort of doesn't count.
But here's there's
another dot, and I
can get from this one
to there by going out
here without crossing black.
Here to here, here to over
here without crossing black,
and so on.
So that cyan structure is
a tree-- has no cycles.
Which in general is good
news for algorithms.
Trees are relatively
easy to find algorithms
for using dynamic programming.
If you've seen dynamic
programming for trees,
this is not like that.
It's a little different because
we don't know what the tree is.
We have to figure
out what the tree is.
But basically, we can
guess the tree recursively.
So there's some first
node-- I don't know,
maybe it's this one--
just guess that.
Not randomly, but guess
means try all the options.
So you guess some node, and
then OK, we've got-- maybe
we've got two subtrees.
Maybe we've got three.
I think that's about
all there could be.
And so, just guessed that,
and then so recursively guess
a subtree here and
a subtree here.
And each of the sub
trees corresponds
to a sub segment of this--
of the original map.
The spine, roughly speaking.
And roughly speaking,
these portions
do not interact with each other.
There's this issue of
how the rays align,
and that's sort of the challenge
in getting this algorithm
to work.
But you can essentially
locally check
whether a subtree
is good enough.
That it will interact OK
with a different subtree,
and just split this
problem up recursively
guessing all the way.
Effectively trying all
trees, but in polynomial time
instead of exponential time.
Forget the running time is
something like n to the 10
or some really big constant,
but at least finally we
know 2-by-n maps can be
solved in polynomial time.
We give the mountain
valley assignment.
We still don't
know about 3-by-n.
That's the open question, and
these techniques unfortunately
don't seem to apply.
You definitely don't
get a tree anymore.
You might get some
nice structure that's
kind of vaguely tree
like, but this was already
super complicated.
So we've gotten stuck here.
Any questions?
All right.
That's it.